now you run when you talk about your
co-stars you're quite open about talking
very French I don't remember you you
gave an interview to Elle magazine and
they asked you about your various
leading ladies do you remember some of
the things you said about them I think
it was regrettable well Emma Thompson
clever funny mad as a chair do you know
him yes in fairness but a man chair
renée Zellweger delightful also far from
saying fair she's she is genuinely
lovely but her emails are 48 pages long
Wow
can't understand a word of them I put
them on Twitter that Sandra Bullock is
genius a German but too many dogs then
we get into a run of these Julianne
Moore brilliant actress loathes me yes
Rachel Vice clever beautiful despises me
yes to Barrymore made her cry hates me
it can't be true junior definitely hates
me Rachel Weisz I think we got on fire I
don't know why I said that
maybe I was going through comedy triple
either who was the third one at drew
Barrymore she made the mistake of giving
me notes which I would you take that
what acting with someone on it actually
like okay well didn't I
go take a litigator because Meredith
heard you speaking about how you are now
sort of aware of the effect you have on
a cast oh yeah why don't you say you
were terrified you weren't really
terrified because the first day I worked
with you I forgot my lines I loved that
I year here's an interesting question I
meant to ask you all these months and
never dead are you ever nervous were you
ever nervous oh if you didn't ask me
that
did I mom Josh every day you ask me that
don't you nervous
second week I'm not nervous of this year
but when we got up when we get up at
Carnegie Hall was shaking yeah I was
terrifying and that was late in the
shoot um and when I had to you know at
the end yeah well that's not easy no I
guess I get nervous I get nervous on
chat shows chat shows are hard
Ostara genius out and how you do it you
put the most uptight people it relaxed
but it is very tough but you are relaxed
you're nice I'm really uptight still
lady rungs was sort of artificial
because it was the knack I was the
actress playing the front attendants
woman yeah at the same time I was an
American actress playing the British
woman